sticking with politics Nikki Haley who
we can now describe as Republican
Presidential Contender Nikki Haley holds
her first campaign event today in South
Carolina she's a former governor and U.N
Ambassador and the second candidate for
the GOP nomination after someone you may
have heard of former president Donald
Trump Robert Costa is in Charleston
ahead of the event today Bob good
morning
good morning to you Tony former
Ambassador Haley is the first Republican
to jump in and formally challenge Donald
Trump in this race but this field could
be expanding soon and fluid in polls
show she might face an uphill climb
I'm Nikki Haley and I'm running for
president jumping into the 2024
presidential race former U.N Ambassador
Nikki Haley made it clear she's up for
the fight I don't put up with bullies
and when you kick back it hurts them
more if you're wearing heels the 51 year
old former South Carolina governor
touted her background as the daughter of
Indian immigrants played Opera
diplomatic work as U.N Ambassador in the
Trump Administration and argued it's
time for generational change in the
Republican party but her decision to run
is a flip from when asked in 2021. I
would not run if president Trump ran
and I would talk to him about it in a
statement Tuesday Trump reminded her of
those past remarks and wished her luck
but the spokesman for his Affiliated
Super PAC called her just another career
politician who started out as a never
Trumper the next president of the United
States Marco Rubio in 2016 Haley backed
Florida Senator Marco Rubio in the
primaries now he has this advice on
facing Trump and the coming attacks it's
a tricky balancing act as I learned in
my campaign it's not an easy thing to
pull off or to do I've been running for
president's heart running against Donald
Trump is really hard but Rob Godfrey a
former top aide to Haley says she's
ready she's able to throw a punch and
absorb a punch very effectively
something that he's probably not used to
other Rivals could launch in the coming
weeks including South Carolina Senator
Tim Scott and Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis is already drawing intense
interest from major donors and from
Trump let's say there it is Trump at 71
Rhonda sanctimonious at 10 DeSantis was
koi Tuesday when asked about whether he
would jump in soon wouldn't you like to
know
[Applause]
from here Haley will head to New
Hampshire and then to Iowa her longtime
advisors and allies tell us she wanted
to get in now so she could have a direct
exchange with voters and with Trump
before others get in Gail
oh it's going to get very interesting
thank you very much Bob